[Music]
doing good makes you feel good but we
wanted to make some dream gooders feel
even better watch this
hi my name is alice bob i am from rio de
janeiro brazil and i am the owner of
mooney's coffee joint in lyndonhurst new
york
i have always loved coffee and i love
communicating with people with all the
the situation with the pandemic we
wanted to do something so i got an old
board that's how we started so you come
to the coffee shop you grab your coffee
you add it to your view another coffee
bring your coffee forward to somebody
else that you don't know and you add
post it from the board and another
person who comes out later on is to grab
that procedure he's going to use for
their own drink with a beautiful note
from you
then from there we have been from 400
maybe 500 post-its already and we had
letters from people from different
states i have people sending me money
that board is showing how much you care
and how much you want to brighten up
somebody else's life it's pretty much
love love love all the way around i
think it'll be forever there
cheering people's life
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh my god it's so soft
oh my god i love it
so cool
oh man thank you
this is amazing
this is so cool
thank you drew for being part of it
thank you so much
to all the true gooders out there thank
you
[Music]